I want to stress one thing we want you
to all to have a good time tonight we
really do but we also wants you to be
safe okay
that's why I've hired a special security
guard to watch over the show he can see
anything that's going on in the theater
and help out he's the founding member of
the Fantastic Four let's give it up for
mr. fantastic mr. fantastic tell us
how's the crowd tonight
oh they're fantastic
thank you Thank You mr. Fuentes for
helping us out we appreciate it
well no problem and well I have
everybody's attention I just want to
remind you that in case of an emergency
there are exits behind you on the
balcony as well as backstage just down
here through the hallway I just want to
watch for the green exit sign above the
door okay thank you very much we
appreciate it good to have you here now
moving on one of the big movies coming
out paintball hey stop it stop okay wait
wait what's the problem mr. mantis
what's the problem
sorry Kona I just caught a fan down
there trying to record the show on his
cell phone but don't worry I confiscated
it I got it thank you thank you yeah
that was great I appreciate it but if
you don't mind please don't interrupt
the show again okay huh sorry for doing
my job a little passive-aggressive there
but all right all right as I was saying
one of the biggest movies they're coming
out right now hey LaVon it is that no
truant governor theater okay what is it
now nope come on LaVon but give me that
gum just spit it out put all of it
trying to do a show okay look I don't
care if he's chewing gum or not all
right if you interrupt the show again
I'm gonna have to ask you to leave I'm
sorry come on you know what maybe I'll
just leave right now you know I hear
it's nice outside
I hear the moon is out the moon is out
what are you talking about
that's just stupid now
we yeah yeah that's great yeah we get
Dumber every year and that's really
you